hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome ooh good song anyway welcome
to a very perverse game of truth-telling
this cold hard truth this is the truth
or wet challenge this is the truth or
death challenge either way what's gonna
happen is we've got Ethan here and he
can't he can't hear a word that were
saying so he is completely ignorant to
everything that we're gonna be doing to
him and he has no idea why he came over
here today he's sitting in that chair
we're gonna play a kind of game of -
truth isn't a lot basically I'm gonna
quietly whisper into his mouth good eyes
I'm gonna use my lips to shoot my
information into his eyes he's gonna try
to read my lips and not only does he
have to determine what I said he has to
judge whether what he thinks I said was
a truth or Allah makes sense if it
doesn't you'll see real soon
are you ready good drums ready yeah
yeah ready I guess so okay don't have a
choice all right are you ready am I
ready you bet I'm not but I'll do it
okay cool do you know what's happening
here okay cool so do you know what's
happening here
nice yes nope nope okay he's got double
layer of protection not only does he
have music blasting but we've got
industrial-strength earmuffs here that
are meant for construction sites with
loud operating machinery so I'm gonna
come up with the truth or alive and he's
gonna judge it as such I get three tries
right okay one more time all this slower
[Music]
ah I grew up in a small town called
Milford isn't it wait you can go again
you don't have to do that yet I grew up
in a small town called Milford that's
all you said once in a truther was it'll
I deserve that one so he's gonna be in
that hot seat so the point of this is
once he's able to not get ice dumped on
him we rotate out who's sitting in that
chair and you would have had that I Eve
would've immediately yeah you wouldn't
yeah all right put it back on this is
the worst and he has to keep getting
dunked until he gets it right so until
that happens all right so now that Ethan
was an idiot he has to stay in SC but
Tyler and I we get to switch and now
Tyler's at risk of being in that scene
next so are you ready am I ready yeah I
won a state title clean water pool I
think he said something about water polo
go in I won a state title clean water
I think you said oh wait I think you
said I won a States and water polo or
something along those lines which I
believe to be true
I'm good are you ready I can't hear what
you're saying but I'm ready I'm
terrified
erm I know so much about me I gotta be
very careful about this one summer
vacation I worked during the summer as a
carpenter that would be true okay mr.
man time to get your medicine okay honey
ready when I was young I had a lizard
named Cody that was like that was like a
paragraph that's what yours was like you
can't hear me when I was young I had a
lizard named Cody oh when I was ten I
had
my house oh good
do you want to know what I said no okay
What did he say in college I played
lacrosse in art school I played lacrosse
falseness
why were you so good I think it's good
did I get it I think well I think judges
actually said was in college I played
lacrosse hold on
I can still hear you cuz I got a
tightening since his head's big [ __ ] you
you in 2010 I was the level 8 regional
champion that's like a mile long what is
this in 2010 I was the level 8 regional
champion in school I was never a good
student not even close
[Applause]
not that cold all right talking like
this Oh high school in high school I
took ap chemistry balls no nobody's
right god damn again know too much about
me did you hate the others no I didn't
think I took ap physics not anything
chemistry god damn it I'm in here
alright ready big boy
ready as a senior I didn't take a math
or a science
why is he long this [ __ ] here as a
senior I didn't take a math or a science
in something school I didn't take math
or science true true ha ha ha
uncomfortable in college I mastered in
sports administration in college I
mastered in sports and education no
mastered in sports administration that's
true dammit rectum did you hear that he
said rectum
I didn't lose my virginity until I was
24 that's false
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no because I said 20 years
oh you would have been like after you
get it once it's not as cold the second
time I would tell them that once you get
it one sure I have had four dogs
I have had four something I have had
four dogs I have had four dogs true
there's an ice cube so because I like to
change the rules on the fly we're gonna
start dumping on the head now originally
we were going to protect it the
headphones don't get you know hit but I
think it's
Oh Greece I read something about your
ass this isn't a fair question
we first met in third grade you say it's
north I say it's third I won't fit in
Milford in third grade and say I'm
saying false ID you're a liar you're
gonna burn for your life totally an
unfair one so if you want to get a free
dump on me you've to go ahead and do
that I said that was an unfair question
because I say it was third grade he said
it was fourth grade but because it's you
it's false oh oh so you did get it all
right I I got caught up in the heat of
the moment because I got him but then I
didn't got him so he gets a free dump on
me
okay you go now it's the RZA oh boy let
me drive my hands first
we don't have towels okay that's fine I
got some type matches around my ankles I
need to think of something that will
make mark look bad he doesn't even
remember my name
my birthday is October 25th people think
something-something it's covered in
filth people think that no that's it now
don't do it you lie to me people think
that Carmageddon was made by Dan and
Phil but go ahead no I get another one
my brother was buried in an avalanche
dan and Phil okay okay here you have one
more try oh you have one more try keep
the QI off I get to fill this up
completely and dump it on you if you get
it wrong what no I don't agree to that
I'll just take what's there now what
would know we're doing it anyway you
don't get to make the shots ready no you
have to answer true or false
my birthday is October 25th true or
false
no no no I'm figuring this out wait so
you don't wait okay shut up shut up shut
up shut up shut up you and yours it's
someday yours all right my birthday is
October 25th true or false
[Music]
of a sick balls your birthday you guys
both know mine January
[Music]
if you get this wrong I'm down there oh
yeah well that's not fair that's why
what what don't say it again
oh no 21st
no points second no in 18th no 15 no
second 1324 no get on the family fit get
on the floor that wasn't part of the
deal was it part of the deal 6
yeah 9 now that side-by-side and yeah
that wasn't the deal
26 weekly shares wait what do you say
25th sit down your 45th it's exactly one
month from Christmas I say that all the
time so I just shut that out
that this isn't okay you know I didn't
think it was either but here we are at
this juncture and that's why you
remember your friends birthdays yours
get in the chair so we've got one last
question did we celebrate your birthday
did we celebrate my birthday as a group
together this year like for my 21st I
mean no what do you mean um with us I
can't walk
oh we're gonna bring it are you stay
right there I'm you stay right there so
afraid
dude I'm sober please don't hurt me
please I'm really please don't hurt I'm
really afraid can I take you no leave it
I'm really afraid I'm really afraid all
right it's time okay don't take anything
of it that's not time it's a balloon
[Music]
oh it's a birthday hat are we gonna
celebrate but I feel like okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
sign in no hands while all right so this
has been the truth or death challenge
this has been the truth or wet challenge
this has been the cold hard truth
challenge this has been a horrible
experience if there's anything that I'm
gonna associate with these in the
birthday from now on its paining so
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching this was a lot of fun happy
birthday thank you to Amy and Katherine
for coming up with this whole field and
thank you Tyler for forgiving me for not
remembering his birth so thanks again
and as always see you in the next video
bye bye